Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain a Sci-fi comedy film called “Giohazard.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The opening scene of the movie shows us an
advertisement for the “beautiful girl pill”.
The advertisement claims that the pill
is one of a kind medicine that will
reorganize women’s brain nerves,
and genes, turning them into the most beautiful
versions of themselves. For the first year, the
beautiful girl pill is sold out everywhere because
of its popularity and effectiveness. Any girl who
takes it instantly experiences a change in their
body and face structure. Suffice to say, that the
pill is very successful, if not revolutionary.
However, in less than two years of use, women
begin to feel the side effects of the drug.
Some get severe allergic reactions while others
go brain dead within seconds. On inspection,
it is found that the pill has directly affected
most of the women’s brains, making their
frontal lobe smaller in size. Because of this,
they show confusion and difficulty in doing the
easiest tasks. In addition, they turn emotionally
insatiable and their sense of pain and pleasure
vanishes. The effects of the drug on the human
brain and their genes are far worse than what the
scientists had expected while creating the pill.
Soon, experts find out that the pill has given
rise to a virus called the “beautiful girl
virus” that is extremely contagious. The virus is
airborne but can only transfer through an infected
person’s kiss. Any woman infected by it turns
into a zombie-like creature with an instinct to
kiss every man in their way. But the worst part
is that every man who gets kissed, gets infected
and entirely transforms into a woman.
The protagonist of the movie is a young man
named Qiao Ke. As the virus spreads rapidly
throughout China, Qiao Ke and his friend discuss
what they should do next. They receive a text
from Qiao Ke’s father and rush home to find a
girl tied in the living room. The father says that
the girl is Qiao Ke’s brother who has converted
into a woman because of the virus. Qiao Ke doesn’t
believe it and tries to check the girl’s body but
the father claims that he has already checked and
confirmed that it is a girl. The girl was trying
to kiss the father so he tied her to the chair.
Qiao Ke’s friend says that if the infected kisses
them on any part of their body, the virus will
spread. Suddenly, the father feels a sharp pain
in his chest. They find out that Qiao Ke’s brother
has accidentally kissed the father on his arm. The
father falls unconscious but just when they think
he is dead, he turns into a beautiful woman.
The newly formed girl tries to kiss Qiao Ke and
has to be restrained by his friend. The two accept
the fact that Qiao Ke’s family is dead and the
women sitting in front of them are zombies. Hence,
they leave them alone and run outside. However,
they are chased by an infected woman before they
can get inside the car. They get to the streets
but it is too late as the virus has now spread
beyond control. The streets are filled with women
who kiss all men in their sight. They try to go
to the police but they have also been infected.
Soon, their phone signals are cut off and they
cannot call anyone for help. The two get stuck
on the side of the street surrounded by women.
Qiao Ke notices that the infected
do not attack beautiful women,
so he suggests they get to the nearest clothing
store inside a mall and disguise themselves. But
since they are surrounded, Qiao Ke’s friend offers
to distract the girls and sacrifice himself.
He claims that there is no better way of dying
than being kissed by multiple women. Moreover,
he has never fallen in love so this might be
his only chance to ever get with someone.
Having said that, the guy jumps in plain view
attracting the infected ones. The girls kiss him
as Qiao Ke runs away to the mall. Fortunately
for him, the mall is completely empty and so
is the clothing store. He sits down on the
couch to take a rest and the time fast forwards
to a year later. Qiao Ke still lives in the store
which is now trashed. The beautiful girl virus has
taken over China and according to the radio, the
survivors have formed camps in different parts
of the country. Qiao Ke, however, lives alone in
the store. He dresses up in women’s clothing and
wears a wig to go out and collect food supplies
once in a while. During one of such ventures, he
enters a car to check for supplies, only to find
a woman in the backseat. Trying to save his life,
he quickly runs away but an infected woman follows
him to the store. While he checks the supplies,
she attacks him from behind but Qiao Ke is
saved by a stranger at the right time. The
stranger has a girl with him, who surprisingly
doesn’t attack them. It turns out that she is
infected by the virus but her body hasn’t mutated
into a zombie, meaning that she is immune.
The man introduces himself as Li Wei and the girl
as Xiaoqi. Li Wei is a member of a survival camp
and is on the search for survivors. On his
journey, he found Xiaoqi and rescued her.
Since she is the only woman in China who is
immune, he is taking her to a place called the
tower where a group of scientists has been trying
to find a cure for the beautiful girl virus.
Xiaoqi is an asset to humanity who can stop the
pandemic. Li Wei invites Qiao Ke to the survivor’s
camp because it is way safer than staying at the
mall. The three then go to the parking lot where
Qiao Ke had parked his car a year ago. He tries
to restart it as Li Wei guards them against the
infected. Soon the car starts and they make their
way to the survivor’s camp. Unknown to them,
a man dressed as a woman follows them on a bike.
He is a spy from a rival camp that robs and
steals the supplies from the other camps.
When they get to the base, Li Wei makes Xiaoqi
wear a device to her mouth so the men would feel
safe around her. Even though she is immune, she
still has the virus in her body, meaning that her
kiss is deady. When Qiao Ke is alone with Li Wei,
he modifies the mouth device so she could open it
by herself. Then, the duo meets the investigation
corps, a group formed by the most courageous
men who go into the city to collect supplies.
Their leader is Li Wei, who is now dressed as a
woman. They plan to take Xiaoqi to the tower and
ask Qiao Ke to stay safely at the camp. Xiaoqi,
along with the investigation corp leave for a
convenience store nearby to collect supplies for
their journey. Back at the camp, Qiao Ke finds
the rival spy giving information about Xiaoqi to
his camp. He senses that Xiaoqi and the others
are in danger and goes to save them. Meanwhile,
the investigation corp and Xiaoqi are attacked by
the rival camp. They hold Xiaoqi hostage but the
sniper from the investigation corp fires at them,
starting a shootout. Qiao Ke arrives at the right
moment and brings Xiaoqi to a safer place.
The shootout gets intense and most of the members
of the investigation corp are killed. The only
survivors left are Qiao Ke, Li Wei, and Xiaoqi.
But before they can flee from the site, the rival
group catches them. The leader makes Xiaoqi wear
the mouth device to be safe and plans to use her
for his benefit. But his plans are ruined when
she takes off the device easily thanks to the
modification Qiao Ke made earlier. She then kisses
the leader. As he falls to the ground and starts
transforming into a woman, his teammates run away
fearing the same fate. The surviving three go to
their vehicle which is now surrounded by infected
women. Li Wei offers to get rid of them since he
is still dressed as a girl. He kills all of them
and the three continue to drive to the tower.
When they drive for some minutes, Li Wei asks
to get off the vehicle revealing that he, too,
has been kissed. Qiao Ke promises to get Xiaoqi
to the tower and says goodbye to Li Wei.
At night the duo stops to rest in a secluded
area. They sit in front of the fire and drink.
Xiaoqi talks about her fiance who was killed a
year ago when the virus first started spreading.
It turns out that she kissed him, unknown
that she was infected. Qiao Ke comforts her
and kisses her hand. The following day they
finally reach the tower but are disappointed
when they see no one around. The duo assumes
that the tower was attacked by the infected.
As they brainstorm what they should do next, a
group of infected women attack them. To their
surprise, they are saved by men from inside a
nearby factory. It turns out that the tower is
actually an old factory where a group of soldiers
and scientists have gathered to find the cure.
The leader of the tower, Xiao Cheng welcomes them
and introduces them to his right-hand man, Big P.
They take Xiaoqi’s blood samples for further
research. She then goes to her room to take a
rest while Xiao Cheng shows Qiao Ke around the
facility. He is first taken to the lab where
doctor Hou is looking at some blood samples. Hou
is an alcoholic who has a habit of forgetting
things but he is the best of the researchers they
have. Then, Qiao Ke is taken to the part of the
lab where the infected girls are being kept
so the doctors can study them. But the most
surprising part about the facility is the room
where infants are kept. Xiao Cheng claims that the
babies were rescued recently, so Qiao Ke doesn’t
think much of it. At night, everyone gathers for
dinner. Doctor Hou gets drunk and reveals that to
create an antidote, a chemical must be extracted
from Xiaoqi’s brain, and upon extraction,
she will die instantly. Even after that,
the antidote won’t be enough to save humanity.
Qiao Ke looks at Xiao Cheng in confusion and
senses that he knows everything. He quickly
pushes Xiao Cheng aside and runs away with Xiaoqi.
Xiao Cheng, Big P, and the other men follow
them behind. Xiaoqi accidentally enters a
room and finds non-infected women inside. It
turns out that Xiaoqi isn’t the only one who
wasn’t infected by the virus. But before they
can inquire further, Big P knocks Qiao Ke out.
When he regains consciousness he is told that the
women who are immune to the virus are called the
wisdom species. They have a rare chemical in their
brains that will help to make the antidote. Xiao
Cheng plans to use them to study the virus and to
create a vaccine to end the pandemic. Although his
motive is good, he plans to kill the women for
something that isn’t even guaranteed. Moreover,
he forcefully made his men mate with the captured
wisdom species to give birth to the babies that
Qiao Ke saw earlier. When the women die, he
plans to use the babies for the antidote because
they also belong to the wisdom species.
Qiao Ke accepts to help Xiao Cheng with his
plan for the sake of humanity but asks to
meet Xiaoqi for the last time. He meets her
and tells her about his decision to help Xiao
Cheng. Xiaoqi looks at him in disappointment
but before leaving, Qiao Ke tells Xiao Cheng to
make the women wear his mouth device when they
are brought outside for surgery. Xiaoqi gets the
hint and explains to all the girls how they can
take off the mouth device on their own. The next
day, the girls are made to wear pretty dresses
and are brought to the operation room. They are
also made to wear mouth devices that Qiao Ke has
secretly modified. As the operation starts, they
take the devices off and kiss all the doctors,
infecting them. Meanwhile, Qiao Ke goes to
the area where the infected women are kept and
frees them so they can attack Xiao Cheng’s men.
Their plan works and the girls are finally free.
They get their kids and run away from the
factory with Xiaoqi while Qiao Ke stays
to announce the tower’s truth to the
survivors around China through radio.
He is soon attacked by Xiao Cheng and the two
get into a fight. Xiao Cheng is about to kill him
but Xiaoqi arrives at the right time and
saves Qiao Ke. However, during the struggle,
Xiaoqi is stabbed. At last, Xiaoqi and Qiao
Ke announce the tower’s truth to the survivors
through the radio. They know that there is
no chance for Xiaoqi to survive the injury
but Quao Ke refuses to let her die alone. At last,
they join two wires creating an explosion to blow
up the facility and sacrificing themselves in the
process. Outside, the surviving wisdom species
watch the place burn with their babies. The movie
ends as they walk away determined to end the
pandemic with their acquired knowledge.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.